(sirens blasting)
(rhythmic music)
(jazzy music)
All righty, greetings everybody.
Welcome to "Roll On" where curious Sir Adam Skolnick
and I tap the non-alcoholic keg frothing with frivolity
and matters of note,
stories current that have captured our interest.
We share a few products that we have enjoyed.
We answer some listener questions, get up to no good,
hopefully have a bit of fun while we're at it.
But first, soon to inherit Sylvia Earl's crown,
Lord of Malibu's underwater currents,
his semi deepness himself, Mr. Adam Skolnick.
How you doing?
Semi deepness?
Semi deepness.
Well, you have not gone as deep as Sylvia.
No.
That's a fact.
And to suggest I might inherit her crown anytime soon is,
I don't know, it's borderline-
It's preposterous.
It is (laughs)
I'm throwing it in your direction.
I appreciate it.
You know, Rich, I can't complain.
I am now the proud owner of life insurance.
Wow.
You are a middle aged Jewish man.
Responsible, taking care of his family.
Yeah, if I die tomorrow, April gets a million bucks.
(Rich laughs)
Well, it depends on how you die.
Oh shit, wait.
Oh no, I haven't signed it yet.
So, after I sign it.
If she kills you, she doesn't get it.
Well, not if it's proven that way.
Right, okay.
Do you have a plan?
If I fake my own death, April gets a million bucks.
They have to discover the body though.
Oh, they need a body?
Yeah, there's, you know, caveats to all of that.
Life insurance needs a body?
I think so.
Oh fuck.
Back to the drawing board.
Rich, are you insured?
I am.
How well?
I don't know.
I should know.
I think okay.
You're pretty well insured, are ya?
Okay.
Well, mainly because if something happens to me,
this whole thing stops and there's no business, right?
That's the weird thing with podcasting.
Like, I don't run a business that could continue without me.
Right.
And you're in the same situation.
I am.
I mean, look, listen, Ben and Jerry's has some nice benefits
and I like the life insurance plan they got for me,
but I needed to supplement.
I needed to supplement.
Right, okay.
How's it going over there scooping, scooping the dream?
You know, I came down with scoop elbow.
Have you ever heard of that?
No.
Scooper's elbow.
Little tendonitis?
Yeah, it's like one of the tendons in there.
There's so many, I don't even, I can't.
I used to memorize all my tendons but I stopped.
Is that impacting your TikTok game?
Oh dude, I don't do it for TikTok,
I do it for the soul of scooping.
All right, well, I wanted to say today's Monday.
It's February 14th.
That makes it Valentine's Day.
Happy Valentine's Day, my friend.
Happy Valentine's Day to you.
And as much as I resent state-sponsored holidays
that mandate that we show affection for our loved ones,
I could not resist the following.
I got you a little something.
What?
This is terrible.
Courtesy of the local CVS.
You got me CVS roses?
Yes.
And CVS chocolates?
Roses and candy for the love of my life.
The bromance that knows no bounds.
Thank you, bro.
I got you...
Your gift's in the mail.
Your gift is in the mail.
Yeah.
There you go.
I think I left the price on that too if you want to check.
No, but there is a QR code.
The Rainforest Alliance grew these.
I think if you turn those flowers upside down,
the petals might all fall off of all of them.
(everyone laughs)
There you go.
You got me top quality flowers.
Yeah, I did, I did.
Nothing but the best.
Were these left in a car overnight?
No.
I picked 'em up on the way over here this morning.
Do you have a petal guy at the studio?
A rose petal guy?
No, we could use one.
We could use some flora and fauna here in the studio.
I wish I had a gecko here.
In addition to it being Valentine's Day,
yesterday was the Super Bowl.
How was your Super Bowl experience?
You know, it was great.
Thank God for DVR, for the geniuses behind DVR
that way you can check in on a bathing baby
or help prepare food and clean up occasionally
and still not miss a second of football action.
Right.
Rams, the victors.
LA celebrating.
LA title town.
Three titles in what, two years?
Something like that.
Three sports, come on.
Plus an epic halftime show.
It really was good.
I feared for the halftime show
'cause anytime a bunch of old guys get together, do their...
I knew Kendrick Lamar would be good.
And I had a feeling Mary J. Blige would be great,
a voice like that, it doesn't matter.
You're always gonna be good.
I worried about the other guys, but they were fantastic.
Yeah, I thought it was pretty great.
Fantastic.
And it was entertaining to see certain factions
of the more conservative part
of our culture lose their minds.
Did they not like that?
No, this marks the, you know,
the decline of human civilization,
which is ironic because there was nothing new in that show.
I mean, when did "8 Mile" come out?
2006 or something like that.
But what's the decline of human civilization
that there's not,
there's one show without a country music star?
I don't know.
I suppose.
I liked Anderson .Paak as the drummer.
Didn't see that coming.
One of my top drummers.
Ringo, Jason Camiolo, and Anderson .Paak.
He's cool.
His outfit was dope.
Yeah, it was great.
He was great.
I don't know if people know,
he's got some wonderful hip hop records.
He's collaborating with Bruno Mars a lot now.
He's got a band with Bruno Mars.
But my favorite record of his is called "Malibu."
And I don't know if you know that record.
I don't know that record.
It's fabulous.
Fabulous.
Cool.
I had the exciting good fortune
of attending a Super Bowl party.
You did?
Yeah, Toby Morris, friend of the pod,
invited me to join him at Frank Grillo's house.
Okay.
So, I went to a Super Bowl party.
For people who don't know,
Frank Grillo is sort of an action movie star.
He's in like every movie.
He's gotta be like one of the hardest working men
in show business.
I'd never met him before.
He was delightful.
And he's, I think he's 55, and just ridiculously fit.
Maintains like 4% body fat year round.
He's a boxer.
Anyway, he was super kind.
And we'll see if we can't get him on the podcast.
Oh, cool!
He seemed interested in coming on,
so that might be fun.
Was it weird to be at a Super Bowl party
not really knowing that much about the players in the NFL?
(Rich laughs)
Slightly.
I actually don't think I've watched the Super Bowl
in like 10 years.
I figured.
And I was like, well, LA's in the Super Bowl.
I enjoy the spectacle of the Super Bowl,
but I don't watch football throughout the year.
I'm much more interested in the sports
that we're gonna cover in a few moments.
The Olympics being
at the top of that sort of pyramid of interest.
You know, but professional sports is not my bailiwick.
Be that as it may,
what I love about sports is I bet you could tell me
who the two best players on the Rams are
just from watching a game.
You haven't seen them play all year,
you don't know anything about the team,
and you probably could tell me who they are.
No, we should move on.
Oh.
(Rich laughs)
I enjoyed the commercials though.
It's Cooper Kupp and Aaron Donald.
Larry David won-
Well, Kupp scored two touchdowns.
He did and Aaron Donald-
The game got very exciting in the last five minutes.
Although it was a bit of a slog before that.
A bit of a slog, a bit of a slog.
Anyway, enough of that.
Let's turn to the topics that we wanna get into today.
Let's do it.
Specifically the Winter Olympics.
But I wanna talk about the Olympics
through this kind of interesting lens of declining interest,
right?
Have you been watching the Winter Olympics?
Like, what is your perspective
on how this has been transpiring
in terms of the media attention
and just general, you know, public engagement
with what's happening?
I have not been watching it.
But I have been reading stories on it
because some colleagues of mine
in The New York Times Sports are over there,
and they do a fantastic job every Olympics,
and they're doing a great job again.
And so, I kind of have been cluing into the main stories
and the winners.
And for me it's because it's, you know...
It's a tough one just because of my life right now
with a little one.
Like, I can't really make time to like sit down
and absorb these longer events
and all these heats and all that,
you know, after the kid goes down
because I'm up at like 5:00.
So, there's really no time for it.
And so that's really the only reason it's,
and then in general,
I kind of don't tune into the Winter Olympics
in a regular basis anyway.
Like, there are some times I do there.
There are some years I do some.
Some, it's not years.
Some, what's the word for four years?
I don't know.
Quad annual.
Quadrennial.
Some quadrennials I do tune in,
but this quadrennial I have not.
Yeah, it's interesting.
I mean, I think, you know,
certainly there's some amazing stories,
and NBC is covering it in the way that they always do,
and now they have Peacock so you can stream it,
which wasn't the case in the prior Olympics.
And you would think with that,
there would be this sort of audience capture.
But my sense is that that's not the case,
and it's left me kind of reflecting on
what the Olympics mean personally and at large.
And when I think back, you know,
over the course of my own life,
the Olympics has been huge as an inspiration
and as a motivational force in many decisions
that I made in my life.
Like, I remember being a kid, I'm older than you,
and just being obsessed with the Olympics.
And this was a time when Sports Illustrated really mattered,
and you would wait for that latest edition
to come in the mail,
and there would always be an incredible photograph
on the cover.
They did a such a wonderful job of covering the Olympics.
And, you know, within that
in the context of the Winter Olympics,
like I have vivid memories of the Miracle on Ice,
the 1980 US hockey victory that became this movie,
which is actually a really good movie.
Have you seen "Miracle?"
I have seen "Miracle."
It's been a while.
"Miracle" holds up.
But I mean, I remember,
I mean, I'm old enough to have been kind
of a semi-conscious sports fan in 1980.
That was the most remarkable team.
That was probably, if you had to pick the Olympics
that really turned me onto it, that was the Olympics,
the 1980 Winter Olympics.
Yeah, it was incredible.
So, my first favorite Olympics was Winter Olympics.
Right, so we had the Miracle on Ice
where literally the whole world stopped,
and everybody was tuned in to what was happening.
And it was a, you know, incredible monoculture moment
that now in today's fractured, you know,
kind of media ecosystem is rare.
Those moments are few and far between.
I mean, the Super Bowl is one
of the few remaining things like that
and the occasional Marvel movie.
But beyond that, you're hard pressed to think of things
that happen in sports or in culture in general
that make everybody pay attention at the same time.
It just doesn't exist.
The Miracle on Ice was like an incredible moment.
And I remember, you know, Mike Eruzione and Jim Craig
and Herb Brooks, the coach,
and all the intrigue around that.
And I think the movie, if you haven't seen "Miracle,"
it does a really good job of capturing that,
and it does hold up.
"The Rewatchables," which is a Ringer podcast
where they go over old movies,
they did a recent episode on "Miracle,"
which if you're into that kind of thing was super fun
to listen to.
I listened to that when I was in Hawaii.
Oh, that's cool.
And then beyond that, like my personal,
one of my favorite athletes of all time
from that same Olympiad was Eric Heiden
who won five golds in speed skating,
set four Olympic records, one world record,
gathered more medals personally than any other country
in that Olympiad,
other than the Soviet Union and East Germany.
And then he becomes this pro cyclist for 7/11,
and he was one of the first crossover athletes.
It's like, I remember that cover of Sports Illustrated
when he was in the all gold like body suit,
and his quads were just enormous.
And I just thought that was the most unbelievable,
coolest thing I'd ever seen
'cause I didn't know anything about speed skating
before that.
Yeah.
The-
And speed skating is like made for television.
It is such a cool-
It's pretty cool.
It is such a cool thing to watch.
Yeah, it's very cool.
Yeah, yeah.
Just the way in which the Olympics,
even with sports that are so kind of askance
of mainstream interest could galvanize the world
for a given moment in time,
it just doesn't feel like that's the case right now.
And there's a lot of reasons for that,
which I want to get into.
Not the least of which is, you know, doping scandals,
IOC corruption, and just our fractured media culture
where there's too many choices,
and it's very difficult to drive everybody's attention
into one thing.
I mean, when the '80 Olympics was going on,
there was like four TV channels
and that was basically it.
Right.
And you had to watch when it was happening,
you couldn't tape it or, you know, time delay it.
And there was no Twitter or internet-
Who they would delay it for you.
They would delay it for you
and funnel it to your prime time.
It was very easy to avoid knowing what had happened.
It didn't matter because the newspapers wouldn't report it
'til the following day.
So, it didn't matter if it had happened already.
There was like,
unless you're like paying attention to the radio news,
you weren't gonna get that headline until the following day.
So, they could delay it 'til dinnertime or after.
And when you think about why, you know,
sort of the sheen has faded off the Olympic brand
and why it's this brand
that I think you can make a fair argument is in decline
is the dissonance between what it stands for,
which is like principles and values and ethics,
has been tainted by so much controversy and corruption,
and this dissonance between what the Olympics represents
and what it actually is in reality,
there's a huge gap there.
And of course, then that's even further handicapped
by our media dispersed culture.
Media dispersed meaning?
Meaning like there's just too many choices.
Right.
You miss the old days when the brainwashing came right
to your living room.
And I welcomed it gladly.
I let the propaganda wash right over me.
Yeah.
As I draped myself in the American flag.
And then at like 2:00 in the morning,
the American flag came on your television,
then it went to the white snow, whatever that-
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, the static.
Exactly.
Boy, those were great days.
How I wish for that.
But I think that played a big part
in me wanting to be a swimmer
and just loving everything about the Olympics
and the Olympic movement,
and then being able to train with other Olympic athletes.
It's played such a huge part in my life,
which is why, you know, it's so dispiriting
to me personally to see this thing kind of falling apart
before our very eyes.
And so, to kind of further get into, you know,
the hows and whys of that,
I wanted to draw attention to a newsletter
that David Epstein puts out.
David being a friend of the podcast.
He was on in 2016, episode 466.
He's the author of some great books, "Range,"
"The Sports Gene,"
and he has this newsletter called Range Widely.
And he posted this article-
Great article.
Called "The Olympics Have an Integrity Problem.
"Here's How to Fix It,"
wherein he interviews this guy, Steve Mesler,
who's a three time Olympian
who had won a gold medal in bobsled
and is now a board member of the United States Olympic
and Paralympic Committee.
And what was so interesting about this interview is
how frank this guy was
because he was sort of talking outta school
in terms of what he thinks is going wrong as a current,
you know, sitting board member of this organization.
Being the USOPC.
Right, and, you know,
we could point to a number of factors.
I mean, the fact that in,
you know, this came up in my podcast with Brian Fogel,
the documentarian behind "Icarus"
who explored Russian state sponsored doping.
So in 2019, Russia gets banned from the Olympics.
But as we all know, they're like still competing
as the Russian Olympic Committee, which is just,
and we all just kind of like go, "Okay, oh well, I guess."
They were banned before Tokyo.
I mean, I think my...
I think, so when it first happened,
and they had the ROC got to compete in Tokyo,
my sympathies were a little bit with the Russian athlete
that may be clean.
Like, you know, maybe, so I-
Well, if the doping is state sponsored,
on some level like that denigrates the culpability
of the individual athlete.
So, this is not about pointing fingers at athletes.
This is about systemic problems
and power politics that are at play.
Right.
And so, but the bottom line is if a country continues
to violate, then the athletes may get penalized,
but that's just part and parcel of it.
So, you can't like, there might,
even if you're an athlete that is under that flag
and the, you can't trust that country to play a fair game,
then I do understand the penalty,
but then you gotta actually administer the penalty.
You can't like say it's a penalty and then just like-
Find some technicality that allows it to.
They did the same thing.
Putin was supposedly banned,
but then there he is at the opening ceremonies in Beijing
'cause they created some kind of corollary rule
that allowed heads of state to attend
despite the Russian ban.
He was invited by the head of China.
Yeah, I mean, the duplicity here is unbelievable.
And, you know, we have opulent demands by the IOC members,
all the corruption that goes on behind the scenes
with the bidding.
How about the Uyghur athlete lighting the flame?
Yeah.
Which is sort of a,
sort of a political whitewashing of, you know,
a pretty terrible situation.
Of labor camp.
Of abuse.
Within China.
Yeah, within China.
And now I guess future Olympiads are being awarded
without bidding
because, as David points out in this newsletter,
there's a decline in cities bidding for this.
Like, there isn't the demand that there once was.
Like, it used to be this huge prestigious thing
to land an Olympiad,
and now very few cities are even interested in hosting.
Because it costs.
So, people, you'd have to build arenas, you'd have to,
it costs so much to put it on,
but yet you'd still, they would still bid,
they would still make these incredible,
you know, presentations and bid, you know,
I don't know if it got to $100 million,
but I believe it did.
I think it's in excess of that.
Didn't LA decide to defer an Olympiad
in exchange for like $180 million bonus or whatever?
Like, I think David points out or,
is it David or Steve?
Someone points out what happened.
Paris and LA both went for 2024,
and they both won basically.
The Olympic committee said,
"We'll give it to Paris,
"and we'll give you, LA, $100+ million if you'll take 2028."
And then they awarded Brisbane in 2032 without any bids
because they didn't want to be embarrassed
by only having one bid or no bids.
And so maybe now it's like, you're almost recruiting.
It's almost, they're actually having to pay.
There's a desperation with that.
And why Brisbane, Adam?
Because it's awesome.
Well, maybe.
It is awesome, yeah.
I can see it being a cool place to host the Olympics.
But let's go behind the scenes a little bit.
The gold coast.
And understand, first of all,
the kind of political co-mingling between WADA and the IOC
that's highly problematic.
Oh, that's right, yes.
Half of WADA seats are occupied by IOC members,
which is insane because basically, you know,
one of these organizations is a police force
and the other is a promotional force,
and these two things should not intersect.
They should be checks and balances on each other,
and yet they're completely co-mingled,
so much so that John Coates,
who's president of the Australian Olympic Committee
and who is on the IOC board, he's VP of the IOC,
is also president of the Court of Arbitration for Sport.
So, he's overseeing jurisprudence at the same time.
Insane.
I mean, talk about, it's like, you know,
in government you have these different houses
with different responsibilities.
The judiciary and the legislature should not be co-mingled,
right?
And he's also the final,
which, well, the Court of Arbitration for Sport is
the final arbiter of WADA decisions.
And he's leader of the Brisbane bid.
I guess they won.
So, you tell me, you know,
how that came to pass, right?
They won.
So, here we have this unbelievably corrupt
and broken system of bribes and political favoritism
and doping scandals and failure to adhere
to, you know, rules that I thought we agreed upon.
And the writer, like you said,
that these IOC members' opulent demands basically amount to,
David compares 'em to a concert writer
from like a diva star.
And like they're demanding-
They wanna be wined and dined.
Wined and dined.
They want their own traffic lanes.
They want like, I mean, it's crazy the demands they make
and, you know, there's been incredible corruption
in how IOC members are being bribed.
There's accusations of being bribed with money
and prostitutes in that story.
It's a crazy story.
I know.
So, when you think of the Olympics as a brand, right,
what an incredible brand because of what it stands for.
But if you denigrate, like, if you,
if the foundation of that brand is eroded and the principles
and values upon which it stands no longer become,
are no longer kind of like practiced in reality,
then what does that brand stand for?
And I think that's really at the root of the denigration
of the Olympics,
and I think in turn, people's interest in it.
Like, there's a cynicism now and kind of less sanguine,
you know, relationship that we all have
because we've been clued into some of these things
that are going on behind the scenes.
And, you know, I don't know if it's worse now
than it always has been,
or maybe we're just pulling the covers better
than we ever have before, but it's a problem.
You know, I feel like the Olympic brand is sort of
in free fall,
and they're trying to do damage control
at a time right now while the games are going on
where it should be all about celebrating the athletes
and the spirit of what this is kind of about.
I agree with you.
I think that we're at a time in human history
where this disparity between the wealthy and the poor is
at the biggest I think of our lifetimes
and maybe the biggest in history,
and that kind of greed I think does infect these brands.
And I think it's twofold.
I think probably there was always a certain amount
of corruption and racism and cynicism built
into these structures that we all revered.
But I also think that there was more honor.
I do think there was more honor, organizationally.
I think there was more honor in terms of how people,
you know, being fair and having certain values,
and honoring the brand itself.
I mean, you could look at any sport,
like everything's up for sale.
Corporate sponsorship left and right.
And so, when you get into that place,
the money becomes the God and the values are secondary.
Now maybe money was always that way.
But I do think that it has eroded a bit more
in recent years, in recent decades anyway.
At the same time,
I think that everything's up for review right now,
so it's not surprising to see the Olympics get the,
you know, just as FIFA's being exposed,
just as the NCAA has been exposed, USA gymnastics,
the IOC is being exposed,
and you can just, you know, peel back every layer
of almost every institution and you'll see exposure.
And what is kind of scary for me is when you start,
when all these institutions start to crumble
at different times, what replaces them?
And, you know, so you don't want these things
to completely collapse because we do need institution,
like institutional pillars to keep us,
I think to keep us within the guidelines
of a healthy society.
But at the same time,
you can't abide some of the crimes that we're seeing,
some of the corruption that we're seeing.
So, what happens?
I'm not so sure,
but I agree with you that there's certainly trouble.
I also think though that when fans are back in the arenas
and the Summer Olympics come back around,
which are more popular anyway,
and it's in Paris, it could be a different story.
Yeah, we'll see.
I mean, I guess the question really is,
is the IOC beyond repair?
Can it be, can these problems be resolved
within the current context of how it operates?
Or do we need to, you know,
basically create a new IOC from the ground up?
Like, who polices the IOC?
And how can we root out this corruption
and hold these people accountable and get people in there
who share the values of the Olympics,
you know, that have integrity?
And, you know,
how can we eradicate the undue monetary influences
that are causing some of these, you know, corruptions
and scandals?
I'm not sure you can.
Because it used to be, it was all about amateur athletics.
That ship sailed a long time ago.
Which is fine.
I mean, I think we wanted,
we always wanted the best athletes to compete.
So, I mean, it's like,
you need the best in the world to compete.
The athletes need to make a living.
Before you had athletes trying to be amateurs
and they couldn't make a living.
And then afterwards, you know, it's still that way,
but it's at least they have a chance to make a living
when they're at their peak earning potential.
And so, I think it's great.
I think Lindsay Crause wrote a devastating column.
Yeah, she did.
In The New York Times.
And the lead to this story,
I mean, I'll just read a couple paragraphs.
This is what's happening.
This explains why I haven't watched.
"Imagine a dystopian Olympics.
"Maybe it would have athletes skiing on fake snow
"down parched slopes.
"Robots mixing cocktails, making dumplings,
"and disinfecting the air.
"Events staffed by workers, not in sportswear,
"but hazmat suits.
"Instead of a stadium,
"you are eager to get a seat in a bubble you cannot leave."
Yeah.
(Adam laughs)
There's a line in this article,
"The Games wreak of societal decline."
Yes.
It's very, it's a very pessimistic view.
And she says at the bottom of the fourth or fifth paragraph,
"Instead of showcasing the best of what humanity can do,
"this Olympic seems to reflect what we can't."
And so, it's a more pessimistic, you know,
take on kind of what David was talking about in his piece.
It is.
And it's dispiriting,
and it's not helped by the fact
that there's a nuclear power plant
right behind the ski jump.
Yes.
(Rich laughs)
But like...
It's true.
How did that happen?
But then there's a lot of people
who think nuclear power is an answer to the climate crisis,
but the ski jump itself, if you look at it,
if you strip it down, like to people like Eric Heiden,
or the ski jump.
I mean, the ski jump is just mental.
They fly so high and so far.
And I mean, that's one of the great sports,
that's what the Olympics are about.
These sports you don't normally tune into
that can be so captivating.
So, you know, it still has the core.
The core is still there.
You know, the events, the athletes.
The purity is in the athletes.
It always was, you know.
There's a flickering, tiny little Olympic flame
at the bottom of a very deep,
deep hole.
It's not out yet.
And it still continues to flicker.
Well, let's put a little more water on it,
and then we'll fuel it back up with some good stories.
Yeah, we do have some good stories I want to share.
But what's the final douse of water you want to throw
on this fledgling flame?
The Kamila Valieva
situation.
Yes.
The Kamila Valieva situation.
So, walk me through this.
15 year old Russian figure skater,
basically Nadia Comaneci on the ice,
tested positive for the angina drug in December.
And she basically is this prodigy.
The drug helps you, makes you more efficient, I guess,
in athletic endeavors.
It's called trimeta...
Trimetazidine.
Yeah, it's a cardiac metabolic modulator proven to,
you know, proven to improve physical efficiency.
Anyway, this test came in long before the Olympics,
but it was still tested positive for it.
And it's a 15 year old girl,
so at first they didn't,
the Olympic committee did not identify,
or WADA did not identify who it was.
But she had helped Russia to team gold.
She was favored to win gold in the individual rounds
as well.
And it was sad 'cause you know
if a 15 year old girl is taking a drug like that,
she's doing what she's being asked to do.
Of course.
And Katarina Witt,
two time Olympic figure skating champion,
is quoted as saying,
"What they knowingly did to her, if true,
"cannot be surpassed in inhumanity
"and makes my athlete's heart cry infinitely.
"Kamila Valieva is a young girl and child prodigy
"who's highly difficult performances
"and grace enchanted the whole world at only 15.
"A minor depending on adults, and she is not to blame here."
So, in defense of Kamila, I agree with that.
What's crazy is the story of who this coach is.
And I wanna make sure I get the name right, this coach.
Yeah, before you get, while you're locking that in.
I mean, look, you know, complete prodigy, this poor girl,
and you could see the stress on her face
if you're watching her in the wake of this controversy.
First to land a quadruple jump,
you know, helps her team win the gold medal.
What's interesting is she tested positive on December 25th,
and I believe there were some interim competitions
between then and now,
and that result was not reported until the day
after she won gold or her team won gold
but before the metal ceremony.
So, like why did this take so long?
Was there some kind of, you know, political machinations
that delayed the reporting on that?
Because it's not like she's just some athlete.
Like, she's a leading contender for gold.
You would think that they would prioritize that test result.
Strange, right?
And so, she wouldn't have had to go to the Olympics at all
'cause they could have figured it out beforehand.
Right, and so RUSADA, Russian's anti-doping agency,
lifted the provisional suspension on her.
They're the ones who oversee, you know,
anti-doping for not Russia.
And here we are in this quagmire, which is not helping,
you know, the Olympic movement.
Like, how do we move forward from here with this girl?
This poor girl is caught in the middle
of an international scandal
regarding once again Russian athletes and doping.
And I think that kind of the institutional problem
that the Olympics have had is if you follow gymnastics
here in the US, there are these young women and girls
and young athletes in general are being crushed
by this system.
You just don't see it too often.
And now this is an example of someone who is very publicly,
and it's happening in real time.
Not like years later,
after it's over kind of telling the story.
She is...
Her coach,
she competes under a coach named Eteri Tutberidze,
a Russian who has just a bonker story.
I mean, it's like,
it's right outta movie villain kind of like,
you can't even make this stuff up.
She was a skater in her own right.
Never made it as a top skater in Russia.
Moved to the US as a young woman, became an ice dancer,
like an ice show dancer
just cruising around the United States.
Ended up in Oklahoma City
where she lived in a YMCA in downtown Oklahoma City.
She used to have to go to Baptist Church services
to get food, to like be able to eat afterwards.
She was in Oklahoma City a block away, at that YMCA,
a block away from the federal building when it exploded.
And she wandered around in a daze,
broken glass, limbs, blood everywhere.
She is on the survivor wall at Oklahoma City.
That's so crazy.
She ends up-
She's Russian.
Russian.
She moves back to Russia.
She could have stayed in the US.
She moves back to Russia
and decides to climb the coaching ladder.
And I guess ice skating coaches,
there's a bunch of 'em over there,
so it's hard to find the great athletes
and to get into a top position.
So for a decade, she's kind of, you know,
running, working her butt off trying to get there,
finds these great athletes, and now she's the top coach.
She was the top coach before Kamila,
but Kamila was gonna basically cement her name.
And who does she work with?
A physician previously banned by RUSADA in 2007
in a rowing doping scandal.
And so, that's the doctor that is overlooking Kamila's care.
Right.
The former athletes of this coach complain of injuries,
they quit the sport, they have anorexia,
they have depression, they don't come back to the sport.
And so, you know, that's what you worry about with Kamila.
Right, so if there is a silver lining in all of this,
it's that it shines a spotlight on this issue.
But like yeah, that's a crazy story.
Blake, there's a NBC Sports article about this called
"Why Do Figure Skaters
"Under This Russian Coach Have Short Careers?"
So, we'll link that up as well,
and you can see that if you're watching it on video.
And I guess the way that,
the kind of latest as of, you know, Monday, February 14th,
how this is shaking out is
that they're gonna let her compete in the singles,
which is this week I believe,
but they're not gonna have medal ceremonies
for the team event that they already won
or for the singles competition.
So, these other athletes who are innocently caught up
in all of this, don't get to have their podium moment,
which is a tragedy.
It is.
And not helping.
No, none of this is helping.
Let's get you a story that is helping.
But we're gonna...
(Adam laughs)
We're gonna turn to some good news
'cause there's some incredible stories
coming out of this Olympiad.
Some well known, some less well known.
And of course, you know, we just picked a few.
Yeah.
There's plenty more where that came from
because the Olympics is still the Olympics,
and the athletes are still the athletes.
And there are remarkable performances and stories
behind those performances that I think are worthy of noting.
The first being Erin Jackson
who is a 29 year old speed skater.
And she became the first black woman
to win an individual Winter Olympic gold,
winning the 500 meters in long track.
Amazing.
And the story, that in and of itself is such a cool story,
but it just gets so much better the more
that you learn about Erin and her backstory.
So, in the Olympic trials, she slipped,
and her teammate, Brittany Bowe, ended up giving up her spot
so that Erin Jackson could go to the Olympics.
Like, that is crazy.
Doesn't happen.
I've never heard of an Olympian or an Olympic prospect
who qualifies for the Olympics donating their slot
to somebody else because they think they deserve it
or they might be better.
Yeah.
Never happens.
And that is,
this is why that little flickering Olympic flame
deep down in the bottom of that hole will continue
to blaze its light.
It just got a little bigger.
Because of stories like this, right?
I mean, what a beautiful, what a beautiful gesture.
And then of course Erin goes on to win the gold,
and she's the first woman to win a gold in speed skating,
period, since Bonnie Blair in 1994, so it's been a while.
Amazing.
And then when you dig even deeper into this story,
she starts out as an inline skater.
She does roller derby.
Roller derby!
And she's from Florida, which is weird.
We have more to say about this in a minute.
Ocala, Florida.
So, put a pin in Ocala, Florida for right now.
I will, I will put it in there.
And there's video that I saw the other day
on social media of her getting onto,
even though she was this inline skater,
which is rollerblading essentially,
which is its own, you know, competition, its own sport.
Apparently like in 2016, she couldn't skate.
There's video of her like going out onto the ice
with speed skating skates on,
and she couldn't even get her footing.
She's like slipping all over the place.
Literally four years ago.
Although I did read something else
that said she was a figure skater when she was young.
2016 was six years ago.
Oh, that's how old I am.
The dementia is setting in, Adam.
(Adam laughs)
I keep thinking it's 2020.
That's the pandemic mindset, right?
We had no Olympics in 2020.
You're right.
Six years ago.
But in six years from going
from a place of not really even being able to skate,
to winning a gold medal
It's crazy.
is just a beautiful story.
It is.
It speaks to dedication.
Continuing on speed skating 'cause it is my favorite.
I think it's my favorite of all the Winter Olympic sports.
And it's Ocala.
Because it's, you know, it all goes back
to Eric Heiden of course.
This guy, Joey Mantia.
Is it Mantia or Mantia?
Mantia.
I would pronounce it Mantia, but I don't know.
Could be Mantia.
Who knows?
It's probably Mantia.
We should know that, right?
So, he's this short track speed skater.
28 time world champion, world record holder.
He's 5'8", 168 pounds.
He didn't medal in this Olympics.
I think he competed in the 1,000 meters
and the 1,500 meters.
I think he got sixth.
And the team pursuit's still going.
It's still going.
Yeah, so he has another shot of the medal.
But what caught my attention about this guy was a photograph
from his Instagram of this dude's legs.
So, if you're watching on video-
That's crazy.
Check out those quads
'cause I've never seen anything quite like that
with the exception of a bodybuilder.
I will never brag about my quads again.
It's unbelievable.
Like, that's the sort of power that you have generate
at the elite level to be an Olympian in speed skating.
That's like, I'm looking at like Rich Roll's legs circa-
Mine do not,
even at my peak, never looked anything like that.
I mean, there's some work that went into that.
The epic five.
I mean, first of all, you look at that and you're like,
how does that guy not win every gold medal
with those legs?
Well, if it's the best legs comp,
he's the gold medal winner.
Yeah, he definitely wins that.
It's interesting how those
somehow still couldn't power him to gold medals in his,
he's older though, right?
I think he's-
He's 36, yeah.
36, yeah.
So, that's probably-
He's been around for a long time.
But here's where it gets even more interesting.
Where do you think he's from?
Alberta, Canada.
Alberta, Canada (laughs)
Oh, wait, he's American.
Yeah.
He is American.
He is from Ocala, Florida as well.
So, the question of course is
what is happening in Ocala, Florida
to produce speed skating Olympians?
I had to know.
I Googled this.
And it turns out there's an incredible story behind this.
How this small Florida town
with no ice rink produced three Olympic speed skaters.
The third being that woman, Brittany Bowe,
who gave up her spot for Erin Jackson.
No ice rink.
Yeah.
So, it's like this small inline skating club in Ocala.
And this woman who kind of runs this club
that has produced all of like,
ironically produced all of these talented people
that have become Olympians-
Unbelievable.
Without any ice rink in the town.
Aw.
How Olympics is this story?
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
This feels like a movie, you know?
Yeah, it should be.
And they don't even know how they've done it.
So, anyway, I'll link this, this is from Yahoo News,
I'll link this up in the show notes.
It's a great story as well.
It's a pretty cool story.
The stories are just bonkers.
I mean, like that's the thing about Olympics,
and since we're so driven by story,
I mean, that's why the Olympics, as troubled as they may be,
will always find,
they will always be part of the conversation
'cause these stories are too good.
And just in case you thought we were done talking
about speed skating.
We are not done talking about-
Not on Rich's watch.
We are not done talking about speed skating
'cause the other story that really caught my eye
that I thought was fascinating is this speed skater,
Nils van der Poel
who set the world record in the 10 kilometers.
And what caught my interest about this was the fact
that he published a 60 page document
that chronicles his training philosophy
and his training logs,
like everything that went
into him breaking this world record.
And you can find that at howtoskate.se.
And you can download the document and read it yourself.
Like, here's what the website looks like.
How to skate a 10K.
And here's what the document itself looks like.
Like, it's literally like-
It's a white paper.
That's exactly what it is.
And this started circulating around Twitter.
Look, you have a Twitter message.
Oh, I do.
I wonder if it's from me.
It might be.
This started circulating on Twitter and it caught my eye
by Alan Couzens
who is one of the world's top endurance coaches,
also a great follow on Twitter @Alan_Couzens.
C-O-U-Z-E-N-S.
That's how I devoured the white paper through this-
Through his thread.
So yeah, he published a thread
that kind of deconstructs this document, this white paper,
on how to achieve world beating levels of fitness.
And what it really is and why, you know,
I felt like it was important to talk about is
how important this athlete felt
about building his aerobic base.
So, it's back to this zone two discussion.
Yes.
And how crucial it is to build a massive aerobic base
that you can then layer
on top of all of your kind of harder efforts
to break through the glass ceiling on your performance.
It's almost like he said,
what comes out of the white paper is he advocates seasons
where it's all aerobic base,
then all kind of interval training and threshold stuff,
then all aerobic base again.
Right.
And he doesn't do any threshold work
when he was in this like extended period of many months,
just building this base.
And when you look at the work that he was doing,
it's pretty spectacular.
So, here are just sort of excerpted things
from his white paper where he is talking
about the importance of aerobic fitness.
"The stronger I got aerobically,
"the more anaerobic sessions I could do later on.
"I purified the aerobic season."
Meaning during this number of months,
he only trained aerobically,
never went above his zone two level of intensity.
You think it's zone two only,
or could it be zone two and zone three?
I mean, you know, it gets technical with that.
Like, it's not an on/off switch.
There's like a range in between those two.
But I would,
basically what he's saying is,
"I am in my aerobic fitness building phase,
"so I don't exceed that threshold."
And the top end of his zone two would be max efforts
for like mortal human beings.
But he's so fit that he could handle like
just unbelievable workouts.
There's another Twitter thread where he,
here's a typical week.
Monday, seven hours of biking at 260 Watts.
So, for people that aren't cyclists,
maintaining like 260 Watts on average
over a number of hours is you have to be extremely fit
to do that.
He's doing that at zone two.
Next day, six hours of biking at 250 Watts.
Wednesday, two hours of cross country skiing,
four hours of biking at 250 Watts.
Thursday, seven hours of biking at 265 Watts.
Friday, six hours of biking at 240 Watts.
And then Saturday, rest.
Sunday, rest.
So, in a five day period,
he put in 35 hours of aerobic training
and that was just a typical week.
So, that gives you an idea of like what a beast this guy is.
And he was eating like crazy.
He was having like straight whipped cream.
7,000 calories a day.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And putting on weight.
Yeah, he put on five kilos I think.
Explaining how this is, you know, important.
Like, a lot of athletes skimp on their calories
during this phase 'cause they're worried about weight gain,
and he put on weight and was happy with that.
And it also is a buffer against, you know,
injury and over training and these other things.
So, anyway, fascinating white paper.
Very good analysis by Alan
who kind of identifies some core principles
out of this program,
which is A, we already mentioned,
purifying your aerobic season, not having mixed messages,
the idea that the stronger you get aerobically,
the more anaerobic sessions you can do later
because the more aerobically fit you are,
then you can go anaerobic and go back to base more quickly.
Like, you bounce back more quickly,
you recover more quickly.
So, your capacity for that higher intensity work
increases the more aerobically fit that you become.
So, more aerobic capacity,
faster recovery for hard stuff later.
And also he talks about finding joy in all of this.
Like, if you're gonna be putting in that much work,
how can you make it meaningful and joyous in doing it?
Otherwise it's not sustainable, right?
Not everybody is living this guy's monastic lifestyle
to be an Olympic world champion and world record holder.
But I think the principles are applicable
in all of our lives.
And he even, he ran,
part of his training was running a 100 mile race.
Yeah, that's right.
That's that was part of his aerobic training.
Which he said was one of the most meaningful
and impactful things that he did.
Like, it gave him a new sense of what his capacity was
and his capability.
Pretty exciting.
And this is all for a race.
Like, 10 kilometers in speed skating,
how long do you think that takes?
Right.
Like, this is-
What is it?
It was 12.
It was 12 and a half, 12:30.
He set the world record.
So, all of this aerobic work
for a 12 and a half minute effort,
which is you can characterize that as an endurance event.
Certainly in speed skating, it is an endurance event.
But still this is not an ultra marathon
that he's training for.
It's a 12 minute race.
And yet he put in that much work
into building his aerobic base.
So, I think that's instructive
for all of the endurance athletes out there.
I like how that, Alan Couzens gave props
to the Norwegians saying similar to the Norwegian approach
in his thread.
The Norwegian.
See, I feel like they're more dialed in on quality.
They do both.
And they don't purify aerobic and intervals.
They mix it up, but they are very much about fuel.
External fuel is the only fuel.
They're very much about eating and training in particular,
in a particular way, and staying, you know, true to it.
They're both Scandinavian, you know, which is interesting.
Can we talk about my zone two problems?
Oh, I can't wait.
Oh, this is good stuff.
This is really,
I mean, really this is what the podcast is about.
Please tell me your zone two problems.
I'm not sure if you've been keeping track.
Do you know what your zone two is, Adam?
Do you know what zone two is?
You taught me this stuff.
I think it's like 134 to 147.
For running.
So, I injured my back at the beginning of the year,
and I had to take basically a month off.
I ran twice in four weeks because I couldn't.
I ran then I got hurt.
Then I ran once at the two week mark,
and I just wasn't ready.
I had to get some PT.
So, then I came back to it and have been, you know,
but when I, right before I got hurt, I'd been running.
My zone two was down to like a 10 minute mile.
And I started at like 12 plus minute mile for zone two.
And so I was actually trending really well.
And then all of a sudden, you know,
now I'm coming back to it
and it's almost like starting over.
Yeah, it will come back more quickly,
but you can't get around that first phase
of re-acclimating your body to it.
So yeah, it won't come back immediately.
It's gonna take some time,
but that patience will pay dividends.
So you'll just have to
Thank you, Rich.
stick with it.
I will.
Thank you for that zone two update.
Little zone two update.
Little, little thing.
Well, fear not.
The good news continues with the Olympics.
What do we have next?
Actually, this isn't quite great news.
It's good news that veers into some sad and also vital news.
We need to know about it, but it does,
it starts with good news and it...
Anyway, I'll just get into it.
Eileen Gu, freestyle skier.
She is an 18 year old.
Not just the best free skier in the world,
which is kind of, if you're not familiar,
it's basically X Games on skis.
It's like what the, it's slope style,
it's big air, and it's half pipe but on skis.
Right, so that's the distinction
between freestyle skiing versus aerial skiing.
Right, aerial skiing is just-
Going off the jumps.
Going off the jumps and just doing that.
This is big air, which is, you know,
the biggest jump you can do with tricks,
half pipe, and slope style.
And she's the best at slope style.
She already won big air, and she got gold.
She's basically set up for a potential,
a three gold Olympics.
And she's also an IMG model.
Yeah, she models for like Louis Vuitton
and all these like high end brands.
And in China, she's just enormous.
She is a supermodel in China already,
and she's budding, you know, international that way.
And she came up, she grew up in San Francisco.
She grew up in San Francisco.
Started skiing in Tahoe
where her mother used to be a,
she was raised by a single mom,
her mother used to be a ski instructor part-time there
when she wasn't working.
And now she's a venture capitalist in China.
Big time.
But she started the venture capital stuff
in the United States too, as far as my understanding is.
She is, but she decided to compete as Chinese.
You know, she always spoke the language.
She was always connected to the culture,
and she decided to compete under the Chinese flag.
And she's gotten a bunch of criticism for it.
And, you know, more recently, I hate to bring him up
'cause I don't like to give him any press
or anybody who's on his show press,
but Tucker Carlson took a run at her.
He had a guest on, Will Cain.
They talked about her turning her back on America,
a betrayal, how we should be,
you know, should inspire collective revulsion.
And remember, this is an 18 year old kid
who is making decisions that she's allowed to make
for herself.
Just like Naomi Osaka chose to represent Tokyo.
And, and-
And let's not forget like
just because she's a fashion model, she's no dummy.
She got a 1580 on her SAT, she's bilingual,
and she's headed to Stanford next year.
And the implication is she's made a shrewd financial move
or she's made a financial move only
and turning her back on the country.
It's appalling.
First of all, it's a smart thing to do.
If your goal is to maximize your value,
it's not a dumb thing to do.
It's a very intelligent thing to do.
She would never, in this country,
an Asian woman to become the biggest model in the country,
it's almost impossible.
It would, it's so unlikely to happen.
To become one of the biggest athletes in America,
you're competing with LeBron James, Tom Brady,
Serena Williams.
It's never gonna happen as a free skier.
You know, like Shaun White's
as big a winter Olympic personality you're gonna get.
And so there, you know,
she has an opportunity to really grow and to be big.
And if that's what she wants, more power to her.
I mean, look at Chloe Kim.
Chloe Kim just won gold again in the half pipe,
second time she's won it in two Olympics.
And she has gotten death threats,
she's been accused of taking white girl spots on the team.
Suni Lee, the gymnast everyone celebrated last Olympics,
the Hmong girl,
she was getting ready to compete
on "Dancing With the Stars,"
and she was pepper sprayed from a car, called a slur.
And the reason I bring this stuff up is
because what's happening to these athletes
who are very powerful women that can handle stuff,
it trickles down to the real world.
We have an epidemic of mentally ill, unhoused people
attacking Asian elders and women in New York City,
in the Bay area, we've talked about on this show before.
It happens here.
There was another murder just yesterday.
Christina Yuna Lee murdered
in her New York City Chinatown apartment.
She was 35 years old.
She was stabbed by an unhoused person
or someone in and out of the justice system.
A mentally ill person, I should say.
Michelle Alyssa Go,
pushed in front of a train in the subway.
She was 40.
That was weeks ago.
I'm sure you all heard about it.
These people are quite literally out of their minds,
but, you know,
where do you think this inspiration comes from?
It's trickling down from this kind of language and treatment
that we give to people like Eileen Gu,
who is a great athlete worth celebrating.
And yet it trickles down to these kinds of attacks.
My wife has had,
April has had three separate, scary experiences with people,
vagrant type people here in LA.
Three.
She was, one, someone got into her face.
The rest has been yelling at her as they pass by
or she passes by.
This is happening, and Asian women in particular
and Asian people in general are feeling it.
It's terrifying.
And so the reason I'm bringing it up is not
to bum everybody out,
but it is to please pay attention to this,
intervene if you see something,
you know, because it's something that is not ending.
And it doesn't seem to be like we're even trying
to understand what's happening.
Like, how does that even happen?
How does there become this epidemic among unhoused people
that are like putting all their vitriol,
all their anger towards one small group of people-
No, it's completely galling.
And the fact that Eileen Gu would be used
as a political football by somebody like Tucker Carlson to,
you know, denigrate her lack of patriotism,
I just find so, you know, upsetting.
It's ridiculous.
And as somebody who has been an athlete my whole life
and competed in collegiate athletics,
I'm no stranger to foreigners coming to the United States
to train.
Like, half the collegiate swimming programs in the US,
half their rosters are swimmers who came from Europe
or Eastern block countries to come to the United States
and train, and then they go back home
and represent their country in the Olympics.
Like, that's fine.
I have no problem with that.
She, Eileen in particular has every reason
to wanna represent China in the Olympics.
She's a big deal there.
She's on their 30 Under 30 Forbes list in China.
She's widely celebrated there.
On the cover of Vogue, Elle, everything.
Exactly.
It's like she has every incentive to participate
in, you know, that kind of attention and riches
if that's what she's getting
versus what she's gonna get here.
I have no problem with that whatsoever.
And the fact that people are denigrating her
and criticizing her and judging her
for making that decision just belies a level of ignorance
and, you know, frankly, racist undertones
that is deplorable.
And when you hear that, you know what I hear?
Why the fuck would she wanna represent this country?
That's what I hear.
When I hear Tucker Carlson going off like that,
I hear why would she?
Like, why would she want to?
Like, why?
Like, that's what I hear.
So, you know, you're proving the point.
I mean, they are proving her point by going off like that.
And so, you know, which is it?
Are these girls American?
Are they part of the American family?
Are they celebrated that way?
Or are they traitors?
It's like they can't win, and it's gotta stop.
Well said.
Well, let's take a quick break,
and we'll come back with, I promise, some good news.
Yeah, good news.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is The Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people,
for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll com.
Promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
And we're back.
You wanna put a button on the Eileen Gu conversation, Adam,
because we failed to mention one material aspect
of this story, which is her incredible athletic performance
at the Olympics.
Right, I mean, just in the first event,
she basically was in a battle with her competitor.
I don't have the competitor's name offhand.
But she was basically, they exchanged leads.
They traded the lead twice,
and then she had one more run to nail,
and she pulled out her absolute best trick, landed it,
and had like a score over 97, I'm pretty sure.
And she got the gold.
It's the type of performance
that athletes are celebrated for,
and she should be celebrated,
and that's the whole point is
that she's a tremendous athlete, tremendous individual, and-
And her best event is upcoming, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, like in reality, the way I look at sports,
I root for Rafa Nadal and Roger Federer.
I root for international athletes too.
And so like I know your listeners do as well.
You're the same way.
I love a great athlete.
I love watching great athletes perform at their best.
And the idea that it's a big flag show,
I know the Olympics are to some extent,
but at the same time, it's like,
that's part of the reason
I think Olympic viewership is declining as well is-
'Cause the US medal hall is at an all time low.
But also just like the media that has it, NBC,
they typically want to give you the Americans in the race.
They don't give you necessarily the best athletes
in all their heats going in.
And that's a problem in the Summer Olympics too.
And I just think that's myopia,
and I think we're beyond that now,
especially since we're getting media from so many sources.
And we know who the greats are,
and that's who we should be watching.
100%.
Let's talk about Winter Vinecki.
Let's do it.
This is another great story that I came across by ESPN,
wrote this story about this fantastic young athlete.
The article's called "Olympics 2020:
"Winter Vinecki's Unfathomable Journey Makes Next Stop
"in Beijing."
And this is a 23 year old aerial skier
who's at the Olympics.
But her backstory is unbelievable too.
Like, there's so many crazy stories like this
that are underreported.
I mean, I'm glad ESPN wrote this article.
It's a very long read on the history
behind this phenomenal athlete who started competing
in triathlons when she was five years old.
Five.
Her parents were very permissive in letting her get involved
in all of these adventures.
She was very, you know, kind of gregarious
and ahead of her time in terms of like wanting
to conquer challenges.
And at a very, I think at 12,
she had won the Iron Kids National Championship
or something like that.
And then at 14, she becomes the youngest
to complete the seven marathons on seven continents.
14 years old.
She ran the Antarctic.
All over the world, you know, Antarctica, Machu Pichu,
like all these places.
Amazing.
And I think she's the youngest by far at this point.
And then at 12, she leaves her family
and moves to Park City to become this skier.
And quickly develops.
It's only due to injury that she was sort of kept
out of the 2018 Olympics as I understand it.
And now here she is in 2021 competing in Beijing
in aerial skiing.
But it's a very cool heartwarming story
that also involves the loss of her father along the way.
And, you know, a lot of kind of touching,
heartwarming details in there as well.
So, I'll link that up in the show notes.
Shout out Aishwarya Kumar for that story.
She wrote it or, yeah.
Do you know her?
No.
No, but I just wanted to give the reporter some props.
For sure.
Cool.
Like, there she is on a bike.
Like, I mean, how old is she in that photo?
Eight.
And then here she is like running in Antarctica.
Unbelievable.
As a 14 year old.
With her mom.
Anyway, cool athlete.
Cool story.
Check it out.
Very cool.
Shaun White.
He's retired finally after getting fourth at the Olympics.
So, a storied career comes to an end.
So, he deserves a shout out for being the absolute goat.
And I thought he handled, you know,
all of it with quite a bit of grace.
Oh yeah.
I mean, you don't get better than that.
He gets out there.
He leaves all his,
first of all, he fights.
He has to land his best run to get into the final.
Did you see that?
No.
Yeah, so he had to come out-
Oh, I did see that.
Yeah, I did see that.
Just to get into the final.
And he did that and then he was there,
and he is like, "Who knows?
"I'm in the final.
"Let's see what happens."
And you never know with him.
I mean, he is such a clutch performer,
such a groundbreaking athlete in so many ways,
and obviously the greatest ever.
So, it was cool to see him when he came in fourth
to the same two guys he beat last time
when he thought it was his last Olympics.
And the Japanese kid won, right?
I mean, that guy looks so young.
I mean, that's really like how old I am, I guess.
But like, I was like, wow, that kid looks like-
But four years ago he came in second that kid
and he really was young.
He was like 16 or something like that.
So this, so now he's like,
I love that Shaun White's big realization,
his big epiphany was,
"Maybe I have been waiting for these guys to beat me,"
and like having them beat him actually felt good.
And I think he was, it must have been surprising for him.
That's interesting.
Yeah 'cause that's how he explained it anyway.
Sort of like by being beat,
then he can kind of walk away now
and feel like it's complete.
Like, if he had won, then it's sort of like,
"Do I stay in this?
"Like what am I gonna do now?"
And you know what also for them,
it's great for them 'cause they got to beat him.
You know, as opposed to, if he just had hung it up,
it's like the passing of the torch works so well
because it's such a great moment, just in sports,
but also between these two great athletes.
And so pretty exciting to see that.
And, you know, the other thing I thought,
which I didn't know about,
that came out of this Olympics,
a story that kind of bubbled up
and now it's been catching on a little bit is
his physical therapist, she's a doctor in physical therapy,
Ester Lee, been with Shaun for seven years.
And it came out last year that she had stage four,
she was fine, she just felt a little fatigued.
And then she ended up, she had a tumor on her pancreas,
and she was diagnosed
with stage four pancreatic cancer then.
And she's, and you know,
that was very terrifying for her obviously
for obvious reasons,
but her grandmother was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
and then two weeks later died.
So, she didn't think she had any time at all.
And she used to work with Serena and Venus Williams,
was their PT, traveling with them on the tour for years.
She's only 43.
And she's been effusive on social media
about Shaun White's support of her and their friendship
and their connection
and how they've laughed together and cried together.
And, you know, he insisted on her coming with him,
and they made it work.
And she's been having multiple surgeries,
multiple chemotherapy treatments.
And it just so happens that like the break from that,
like you know how it works in the medical world,
you have to go on these rhythms of chemo treatments
or whatever.
It just dovetailed perfectly for this Olympics.
And she made it.
And then was there for this whole time.
And it's just a beautiful story.
It kind of shows Shaun, you know,
the one thing I think Shaun has had a problem with,
he's been so great, he hasn't always appeared human.
You know, he's always appeared great
and kind of above everything in the fray.
And he's even had his own kind of semi cancellation
which was last Olympics that came out.
And to see this, a human side of him,
to show that people are more than you assume and think,
I think is a great thing.
Well also he's older, he's matured.
Like, I think that perspective might
not have been possible two Olympics ago.
You know, 'cause he's a man now.
Grown into himself.
Which is cool.
Well, on the subject of goats,
we have to talk about Kelly Slater.
Hell yeah.
It's unbelievable.
Kelly, on the cusp of turning 50,
won his eighth pipe masters.
Amazing.
It's unbelievable.
30 years of dominance, 11 world titles,
56 tour championships, and just a, you know,
an incredible ambassador of longevity in sports,
like all time.
It's just, it's him and Tom Brady up there.
Well, I think LeBron James,
considering what he's doing at 38 years old.
Is he 38 now?
Yeah, I think so.
What he's doing, and he's 29 points a game,
he's right there.
I mean, you can't really separate him from that group.
And then you have Rafa Nadal who just won his 21st major
at 34, 35 years old.
That never happened in tennis before.
And what is the consistent theme between those three guys?
Four, four guys.
Yeah, super into wellness, I guess.
Super into wellness.
Like, these guys really care about what they put
in their body and all of the, you know,
things outside of their sports specific training
to take care of themselves
and take an insurance policy out on, you know,
those kind of long term career successes
that they've experienced.
And Tom Brady with his avocado ice cream.
I mean, you have Chris Paul, who's a great point guard,
and he's the, you know, the most important player
on the best team in the NBA right now.
And he went plant-based,
which kind of gave him longevity,
and he's been, he was public about it kind of,
but like he was keeping it to himself
because he just doesn't want other people to go plant-based
'cause he doesn't wanna give up the competitive edge.
Yeah, I like that.
I mean, Tom Brady,
I don't think Tom Brady would characterize himself
as quote unquote "plant-based,"
but he is very plant predominant in his dietary approach.
And I don't know what Kelly's diet looks like,
but, you know, I suspect that he's very conscious
about what he puts into that vessel of his.
It's just incredible though 'cause even the,
I forget who won Mavericks last year,
and it was somebody that has been,
he's a legend at Mavericks,
but he's over 50 and he won.
It's not McNamara.
No, no, no.
It was someone who's just a Mavericks guy.
He's up there, he's the guy up there.
But like that's not necessarily the guy
who usually wins a surfing competition.
Right.
And so it's just interesting to see it.
It's really exciting to see, you know,
these guys continue to do it, and women too.
You know, Serena is older, and she's been going to finals
for the last several years until this year.
It's crazy how much things have changed.
I mean, when I was a kid, if you went to two Olympiads,
that was like unbelievable.
And now there's lots of athletes
who this is their fifth Olympiad.
It does seem that way.
Like, there was Kareem and Martina,
and there was nobody else really pushing the age-
Well, there was, a lot of that is money, you know,
because yeah, if you're a professional athlete,
you're getting paid and you're incentivized to, you know,
play as long as you can.
But in almost every other sport,
like you can't make a living
and compete at the highest level.
But now with sponsorships
and the way kind of our economy works,
more and more people are finding ways to make that possible
for themselves, which is cool.
Yeah.
Well, congrats to Kelly.
Yeah, man.
Unbelievable.
So, I think that concludes the sports part
of this podcast.
No more sports?
Not for today.
Okay.
What did we leave out?
I mean, look, we left out a lot.
We picked a few stories.
That's what we always do.
That we thought were cool.
I want people to know that about this show.
I know it's long, we do leave things out.
I know it's hard to believe.
More than a few.
I wanna hard pivot to a different subject matter.
So, the podcast that went up this week is with Johann Hari.
He's the author of this new book "Stolen Focus."
And it's all about our declining ability
to sustain attention and the reasons for that
and kind of the way out of that.
And the reasons range from of course social media
and big tech kind of hijacking our dopamine systems,
but also, you know, lack of sleep, exhaustion, stress,
environmental toxins, all of these things contributing to,
you know, our declining ability to kind of just do one thing
at a time.
And in the context of that conversation,
we were talking about our relationship to our phones.
And Johann in the writing of this book
or kind of what prompted the writing of the book was he went
to Province Town for three months.
He left his iPhone on the mainland
and only brought a laptop
that couldn't connect to the internet,
and the idea was he was gonna live for three months,
like completely in an analog way.
But he brought this, he was like,
"I need to be able to make a phone call.
"So, is there some kind of phone that isn't connected
"to the internet that I could get?"
And the only phone that he could find was this thing called
the jitter bug, which is for old people.
It has big buttons on it.
You know, like if you're half blind.
And if you fall down, it like automatically calls 911.
It's like, it's a geriatric phone, right?
And I said to him, I was like,
"There has to be a better dumb phone than that."
Like, I would love a phone that would allow me only
to make calls and maybe text people.
I'd like to be able to listen to podcasts or audio books
and maybe have like a navigation,
like if I needed directions or whatever,
I could find my way and just get rid of all the apps
and all of that.
A semi smartphone.
Yeah, like, I don't know, middle school phone.
You know, I don't know, like kind of dumb.
Tweener.
A mostly dumb phone.
A tweener phone.
A handicapped smartphone.
I don't know what you would call it.
But it was brought to my attention by my team here
after we finished that podcast that one such phone exists,
and it's called the Lite Phone.
I have a link for it.
Let me find that.
What did I do with that?
Oh, here it is.
Lite Phone.
L-I-T-E.
Thelitephone.com.
L-I-T or L-I-G-H?
L-I-T-E.
L-I, oh, oh you're, I'm wrong.
L-I-G-H-T phone.
The Light, L-I-G-H-T Phone.
And I haven't, this is not a sponsored thing.
I haven't even tried this yet.
Not yet.
I'm gonna order it though 'cause it looks cool.
So, it has only a couple core functions.
Phone, alarm-
Looks like a Kindle.
Yeah, it is.
And it has-
Looks like an iPod Kindle.
It's made to have that Kindle screen
without the blue light and all of that,
so it doesn't like screw up your eyes.
Yeah.
And you can like you can have podcasts on it.
There's a couple like, you know,
customizable features to it.
But I'm gonna try this thing out.
It's premium minimalism.
Exactly.
Premium minimalism.
I like that.
Did you just coin that?
Well, no, it says on the website,
it says it's called, they call it a premium minimal phone,
so I went from that.
I did create it, yes.
I think it looks cool.
So, I'm gonna try it out, and I'll keep you posted.
299.
But I was gonna ask you because I know-
Comes in black or white.
Social media is so connected to the podcast business.
I mean, it is so much about,
it is a big way you're able to keep in touch
with your listeners and build listenership,
and, you know, shout out to your guests and all that stuff,
which is valuable to both listeners and to you
and to the guests.
So, how do, you know, I just wanted to ask you about that.
Like, if you decided to go premium minimalist forever,
like how would that impact you?
Is that something you worry about?
Well, I'm not gonna close my social media accounts
because that is part and parcel of my career
and my business.
But I think there's plenty of room
to have a healthier relationship with all of it.
And these things can live on a laptop.
They don't have to be with me at all times,
so that every time I find myself in line somewhere,
I'm scrolling mindlessly.
And that's really what it's aimed at.
So, I would still like use those platforms,
but be less prone to them using me is the way
that I'm thinking about it.
Can I get Spelling B on the Light Phone?
Probably not.
You can't get Wordle.
That's probably not.
Does it have a web browser?
I think it might have,
you might be able to get a bit, I don't want a web browser.
If they give you a web browser, it's like over.
I know.
Yeah, that's not good.
You don't want that, right?
No, no.
We'll see.
Stay tuned.
The second product I wanted
to bring up is my friend Compton Rom Bada's company called
Ascended Health.
And again, this isn't a sponsored thing.
This is just something that I use that I've enjoyed
and found helpful.
Compton is a microbiologist.
He's a dear friend.
And he was very instrumental in helping me
when I was training for my Ultraman races
by creating these crazy probiotic concoctions
that I would drink for recovery that were all fermented
and had all of these adaptogens in it.
And he was living in Los Angeles at the time,
and I would go to his house
and he would have giant vats of things
that he was brewing up.
And he's like, "Try this.
"And I'm working on this," like a mad scientist.
Like a mad microbiologist scientist.
And I just, I love him dearly.
He's incredibly bright guy.
And he since moved to Utah to kind of grow his company.
And he opened up his own facility for his products
and suffered a terrible fire
where he lost a lot of his fermentations and samples
and all the like.
And he's slowly been trying to rebuild it in the meantime
and actually could use everybody's support
because I think the products that he creates are next level
and wonderful.
And one of my favorites is the skin oil
that he makes called I Am Beautiful oil
that I put on my face.
I feel like I ordered that dish at Cafe Gratitude.
Yeah, it's probably, it probably is a dish
at Cafe Gratitude.
And this is just, it's like a wonderful smelling oil
that you put on your skin,
and it helps with sun damage and aging.
And it's got like marine phytoplankton in it,
like all of these organic like cool ingredients in it.
And I just, I love the smell of it.
So, here I'll slide that over and smell that.
What do you do?
Do you drink it?
No, you just rub it on your face.
Oh really?
Yeah, can you reach that?
I didn't slide it long enough.
And I love Compton.
I love his product.
So, I would start with the I Am Beautiful oil.
It's something I've been using it for over 10 years
at this point.
It's good, right?
Yeah.
I'm into it.
So, check that out as well.
And again, not a sponsored thing.
Like, he's just a friend and I just love what he does.
That can be like, whoa.
So if I start using that,
how long will it take for me to become beautiful?
You're already beautiful.
Aw, thanks.
You are beautiful.
I am beautiful.
This isn't "you will become beautiful,"
you already are beautiful.
It's not, "you could be more beautiful."
I gave you candy and flowers.
Like, now you're feeling needy.
I know.
Now I'm just fishing for compliments.
All right, let's get to some listener questions
for act three of this podcast.
Let's do it.
We're gonna start in New York City.
Yeah, baby.
Hey, Rich and Adam,
this is Brett calling from New York City.
Love the pod, love what you guys do.
Keep it coming.
My question is mostly for Rich,
although, Adam, would love for you to weigh in as well
if you feel it's relevant.
Rich, you have admitted to being prone towards negativity
and cynicism,
and I have to admit that I myself am inclined
in this direction as well.
And I'd love to hear from you
how you actively work against this
to show up in the world not negative, not pessimistic.
You've touched on this in many pods,
but today what I'm looking to hear is really pragmatic,
practical advice on how you work against this.
I think a lot of people out there would really benefit
from this type of advice with the world being what it is
with COVID, climate change, geopolitical issues.
We could all use this really practical advice.
Thanks so much guys, love you.
That's a great question, Bratt.
Is your name, is your name Bratt?
I think it's, maybe it's Brett.
Brett maybe.
I misheard it.
Brett from New York City.
I appreciate that question.
Yeah, you know, it's true
that I am not predisposed to optimism.
My default is not gratitude nor necessarily even positivity.
And I do find myself at times confounded by guests
that I've hosted over the years on the podcast
who seem to burst with unbridled optimism.
And sometimes I struggle with thinking like,
is that really even authentic?
Like, how is that person actually exuding
that level of positivity all the time?
It just happens.
I can't hold it inside, Rich!
I can't, it just comes,
it pours out of me.
I know, it's you.
I'm speaking directly to you.
And like, despite every counterpoint, you know,
I hurl in their direction,
nothing seems capable of derailing that positivity.
And I admire that.
You know, that's a sensibility
that I wish I could inhabit more and better,
but which despite, you know, fleeting flirtations,
I do not consistently exude myself,
so I feel you, Brett.
For example, like just the other day, like two days ago,
I woke up feeling not great, I slept poorly,
and I was just like a disaster all day.
I was dark, I was moody.
I felt angry.
I felt unfit to be around other people.
And I had like no energy or enthusiasm for anything.
And this is like a darkness that befalls on me
from time to time.
In this case, it was directly related
to not waking up rested.
And so, I have over the years developed a couple strategies
for combating this and dealing with this.
And, you know, the first thing is to just accept it.
You know, like to kind of be angry that you're feeling
that way is only making it worse
and enhances the level of suffering
that you're experiencing.
I also think it's important to always remind myself
that like cynicism is kind of a lazy reaction to things.
I think it takes a lot more gumption
and courage to be optimistic and have a positive outlook.
So, I remind myself of that.
When I do feel that way, I try not to dwell on it
or beat myself up for it
again 'cause that creates kind of a vicious cycle
that seems to perpetuate it and make it worse.
And then I try to engage in really simple activities
to help shift it.
Like, go for a walk or even a 10 minute meditation
or, you know what, I'm feeling off,
like maybe I should go to an AA meeting.
And, you know, take those actions
because it's only truly through actions
that you can kind of shift that perspective.
And then beyond that, like trying to remind myself
that it's okay to feel however you feel.
Like, being okay with yourself.
And then from there, you know,
I try to engage in practices
that lead to or cultivate more optimism, positivity,
and gratitude in my life.
All of which I've talked about many times
at length on the podcast.
And I think for the most part are things
that are pretty self evident and not complicated.
And they all trace back to this idea of mood follows action,
this mantra, right?
If you wanna shift your mental or emotional disposition,
you have to do something to accomplish that.
So, are you getting enough sleep?
Are you exercising on the daily?
Are you connecting with nature?
Are you connecting with other people?
Are you of service to somebody less fortunate like often?
And this is, you know, completely a 12 step thing.
Like, if you feel off
or you're grinding on your own, you know, self-obsession,
like pick up the phone and call a friend
who's going through a hard time.
It doesn't have to be some huge grand gesture,
but anything you can do to kind of get
out of your own self-obsession seems
to ameliorate those kind of negative emotions.
And then beyond that, you know, again, simple stuff.
Meditation, mindfulness practices,
a gratitude list which helps shift the narrative
and helps you identify or kind of appreciate
that there are a lot of good things in your life
and maybe, you know, in my case, my life is crazy good.
I lose sight of that
unless I intentionally practice contrary action
and behavior.
So, stop dwelling on the enormity of problems
that you're powerless to solve.
Like, you talked about climate change,
like these existential things.
Like, you can walk around with a cloud over your head,
and it will paralyze you.
So, try to get out of that kind of dooms day scrolling
or dooms day thinking and just focus on
and execute the small things that you can actually do
on the daily and then do them.
And here's the thing.
And again, this is another like 12 step thing.
These solutions,
it's like I'm sure Brett already knows all of this, right?
Sometimes we need to be reminded of them
because inherently as humans like we're annoyed
that the solution or the answer
again goes back to these basic things.
We want it to be more complicated.
Or what's the better solution?
Or what's the latest in science
that can solve this problem for me?
Where's the advanced course?
How can I get, you know, beyond the velvet rope,
and you can tell me the new thing
that I can do to deal with this stuff.
But there is no magic bullet.
It's the same old shit.
And no matter how much you practice meditation
or no matter, you know,
how many times you get a good night's sleep,
like it doesn't carry into the next day.
These are things you have to do consistently
every single day if you're in that place
if you want to emerge out of it.
It's just doing these things over and over again,
rinse and repeat.
And that's not to say, you know,
sometimes people need some exogenous help.
Like, if you have a true case of depression,
clinical depression, or some other kind of mental condition,
then you should seek help for that.
Whether that's therapeutic talk therapy,
which is another thing that, you know, I think is good
and what I've been practicing for many years,
or some kind of, you know, outside help in that vein.
But that's the best answer that I can give you.
And I hope that's helpful.
That was a fantastic answer.
She wanted to hear from you too.
If I felt it was applicable.
I think she senses that I have an internal buoyancy control,
which I don't get into like the,
I don't wake up with like the dark drearies.
But you have a comedic cynicism to you.
Oh, I have a deeply embedded like global cynicism
within me.
I do, I am concern-
But rather than combat it, you cultivate it.
It's part of my persona.
And then you deploy that.
But like, it doesn't,
what I'm saying is it doesn't,
I don't wake up like feeling that.
You know what gets me?
Is when I have a lot to do
and I don't feel like I have enough time.
And like the big stuff, like the real crises,
I'm actually good,
I'm actually able to deal with quite well.
It's the stuff that is actually not a crisis
that I make into a bigger deal than it is,
and it drives me nuts.
So, I'm like kind of the opposite, if that makes sense.
Like, I don't get caught up in like the stuff you-
It's not climate change.
It's like why is there a scuff on my shoe?
It's like there's so many deadlines
and there's other things I wanna do,
and you know what I mean?
Like, and when am I gonna,
it's looking for the next thing is my big dilemma.
But that said, I certainly have really bad days.
And sometimes I am the asshole,
and you always don't wanna be the asshole in the world,
but sometimes you are.
And what I usually, if I'm not doing daily yoga
in the morning or exercising first thing in the morning,
I'm much more susceptible to that.
So, for me, the big, the big thing is movement.
And if I do that and I can usually keep my mind right.
Yeah, you can't be the person you want to be in the world
if you're not exercising some basic self care.
Right.
And then I like I do,
it is important to me to stay in that connection
and all of that.
But like I said, I am cynical in a lot of ways.
I just don't wake up with the drearies too often.
All right, well, let's go to Bill from Crusted Butte.
Hey, Rich and Adam,
thank you so much for what you guys do.
This is Bill Wolfson out of Crested Butte, Colorado.
I am calling to ask a question regarding discipline.
I have the goals and aspirations of being a vegan,
socially, physically, and morally, I guess you'd say.
And I am lacking some fortitude
or some ability to really stick with it,
either based on social influences, my own discipline,
or just inconsistency.
I've gotten past beating myself up for it,
but that was also a struggle for a while.
And now I'm just wondering if you have any tips or tricks
for some of us people that struggle with this.
I'm guessing it's a relatively common occurrence
for a lot of people who love what you guys do
and how you do it,
but they're not 100% integrated
on how we are doing it in our own lives.
Thank you so much.
I hope you can shed some light on this,
and peace, plants, and namaste to you all.
Thanks Bill.
I think that's a great question.
It is a common issue that I think we all confront
in our own ways.
I mean, you use the example of striving to go vegan,
but this quandary I think applies
to any type of habit change.
So, the question first is
why is letting go of bad habits so hard
and why is creating better habits equally hard
if not harder?
Many people smarter than me have tackled this terrain.
So, I would start with the wisdom of James Clear
in his book "Atomic Habits."
We did a podcast together that was very popular.
It was a couple years ago, October, 2018, episode 401.
So, I would check that out if you haven't already.
But I think a lot of this begins
with identifying your values.
And what I mean by that is first being clear
on who you are now and who you aspire to be.
So, the values that you desire to inhabit,
like what does that look like for you?
And then getting really clear on the dissonance
between the two,
the person you are now and the person you aspire to be.
And I think that in between zone...
Within that in between zone,
there is a dissonance that creates a psychic toll
that I believe is a barrier to really feeling comfortable
in your own skin and living as authentically as you can.
So, the less dissonance between those two,
the more fully embodied and empowered you're going to feel
and become.
So, that's the goal, right?
How do we get there?
Well, to close that gap and eat away at that dissonance,
you need to know the end game first,
the person you aspire to be.
So again, back to that clarity.
And then you need to backtrack from there
and identify the steps that are going to get you there.
So, there's a goal,
and then there's the stepping stones
towards achieving that goal.
And I think as you begin to identify those steps
and begin to take them,
a perspective that I think is helpful is to look at it
through the lens of forming new habits
rather than letting go of bad habits.
So, rather than dwell on the bad habits,
which tend to lead you to beating yourself up,
sort of let go of that
or put it in the back recesses of your mind
and focus on the new habits that you're trying to build.
These new steps, these new stepping stones are going
to be the fabric upon which you build these new habits
until they are fully ingrained.
And the way that you do that is you identify
and start with really small doable things
that you can begin doing right away.
Things that are just a little bit out of your comfort zone
but not too much out.
Like, there shouldn't be too much of a stretch.
And then you start knocking them down, like doing them.
And that creates momentum.
And with that momentum,
you'll find yourself more emotionally engaged
with the journey itself.
And then it's about just continuing to keep the pressure on
and increasing the degree of difficulty
of those little doable steps as you kind of progress.
And I think when you do this,
as you're building these new habits,
often what happens is it will crowd out the bad habits
and they will fall away without effort.
So, without even focusing on letting go of these bad habits,
the new habits will create so much space
that there isn't really any room
for those bad habits anymore.
And they will kind of evaporate
without having to put a lot of, you know,
mental effort into them.
I think that it's also important to create an environment
that's conducive to making those healthy changes
and leading you to take those little, little steps
along the way.
So, in the context of this vegan example,
it's like get rid of the foods in your house
that aren't on the program,
and that way you make it additionally more difficult
for you to veer off the path that you're, you know,
trying to walk.
And I think also it's important to be patient
and gentle with yourself.
This is not a linear thing.
It's not about perfection.
If you slip up or make a mistake,
it's not about beating yourself up or abandoning it.
It's about doing a forensic evaluation of why you mistepped
and trying to understand what led you to that choice
and then closing that gap,
so that next time you're not in that position again.
Like, "Oh, I was feeling tired,"
or, "I just had an argument with my partner
"and suddenly I found myself eating this thing
"I promised myself I wouldn't."
Like, you know, first of all, get the thing out of the house
and then understand like,
"Oh, wow, I guess like I veer off the path
"when I'm in this emotional state."
Like, all of those things I think are building
your self knowledge and self understanding
about why you make the choices that you make,
and those turn out to be very helpful.
Back to the patience thing.
Progress is generally microscopic.
Often a other people are able to identify changes
that you've made in yourself before you're even able to.
So, if you're not seeing it in yourself
or you feel like you're not making any progress,
that's not necessarily a pragmatic
or reliable indicator of where you are.
Just keep doing the thing, keep like trotting the path,
and build on that momentum.
And if need be, leverage external accountability,
both positive and negative.
Like, bring people into your life
to whom you're accountable.
Like, people that know you're trying to do this hard thing
that you're checking in with
who are aware of whether you're, you know,
doing it properly or not.
And they can say, "Hey, what's up?
"You said you were gonna go to the gym at this time.
"You didn't show up," or whatever.
Like, the more you can kind of build in those measures,
the more likely you are to, you know, remain on that path.
And I think it's also important because these, you know,
sometimes, like you wanna make a big change in your life.
Like, I want to go vegan and let go of these animal products
that I have been eating my whole life.
Like, that's a large thing that you're endeavoring to do,
right?
So, the best way is to break it down into tiny little things
and master one thing at a time.
So, an example that I always like to give
in the vegan context is, you know,
maybe swap out dairy milk for plant milk,
and put that in your coffee or tea in the morning,
or put that on your cereal, or however you use milk.
And just do that for a period of, I don't know,
six weeks or eight weeks.
And what you'll find is suddenly you won't think twice
about it.
It's just the default choice that you make.
And then you can move on to another category,
and you kind of knock those, you know,
bowling pins down one at a time.
And I think, you know, when you do it that way,
then you're kind of,
you can celebrate these little successes too.
And the more little successes that you can celebrate,
then the better you feel about the progress
that you're making
and the more emotionally invested you are in, you know,
the long term plan of what you're trying to accomplish.
Final thing I would say is it's important
to look inward within yourself
and kind of deconstruct your own psychological framework
because you said in your question
that your resolve often fails
in the face of social influence.
So like why is that the case?
And what does it say about how you feel about yourself
and your ability to set healthy boundaries?
Like, the idea that you would cave who you wanna be
because someone might be uncomfortable with it,
that tells me that you lack a certain level of esteem
to stand in your own truth,
the fact you would change your habits
because you're in a certain social setting
where people might have a certain opinion
about what you're doing.
But each act that you take to align your behavior
with this value set is like a building block
in your fortress of self-esteem.
So, what it will do over time is allow yourself
to be who you are.
And I think you'll find as I have that those people
that you're so afraid are judging you,
not only don't really give a shit
because everyone is self-absorbed
and they're just thinking about themselves,
but that in fact, they will actually respect you more for,
you know, what I would consider to be an esteemable act.
Like, "Hey, I don't do that anymore, I'm doing this,"
it has nothing to do with other people.
This is about your relationship with you and you.
And I think getting clarity on that
and having the gumption or the courage to, you know,
stand firmly in your own value set is
a very attractive quality.
So, that fear of like,
"Oh, I'm gonna cause problems in my social circle,"
a lot of that you'll discover is truly in your imagination.
Like, I remember when I got sober thinking,
"Holy shit, I have to go to a wedding in six months
"and there's a bachelor party.
"Like, how am I gonna go to that bachelor party
"and not drink?
"Like, not only am I gonna be uncomfortable,
"I'm gonna make everybody else uncomfortable."
You're future tripping on something
that hasn't happened yet.
And when you get there and you kind of walk through it,
you get to the other side of it,
and you realize like that just wasn't the big deal
that I thought it was.
Like, nobody actually really cares.
So, value yourself.
And in that valuing, make those better decisions.
That self-esteem will begin to flourish and blossom
and make those healthier choices that align your behavior
with your values even easier.
But first you gotta begin.
So, what is that first step?
What is the thing you can do right now today
that will shift that trajectory and start to create momentum
in the direction that you wanna move?
That was just so beautifully put.
I think I didn't realize
'til just now how much recovery helped you in your approach
to integrating a plant-based diet and just your wellness.
Oh, it's huge.
And like it's so the software.
Like, I heard all that,
and I just heard like the recovery software,
kind of like go into computation mode
and tackle this issue with this software that works
and can be applied so many different places.
It must be such a core element.
Yeah, it's a rubric for, you know,
how I make decisions in all facets of my life.
And certainly, especially when you realize
how much we eat to kind of salve our emotional states,
and you realize that there is an addictive nature to that,
the template of recovery becomes all the more apt.
And I think it's really instructive
for any kind of habit change that you're trying to make.
I love it.
It was great.
Can I add just two quick things to that?
For someone who I'm, as I've said before,
about 95% plant-based, occasionally I do eat some seafood.
I make sure it's sustainable.
I know I'm so sorry.
Sylvia would hate it.
There's no such thing as sustainable fishing, Adam.
You know this at this point.
Well, I-
Your semi deepness,
your semi deepness is now being downgraded.
Listen, so 95%, but that's pretty good, right?
Listen, if everybody was 95%, we'd be in a better place.
So, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna...
So-
I'm not gonna say, I'm not gonna judge you.
You can judge me on your own time.
This not my own time?
This is my own time right now, buddy.
(Adam laughs)
The point I'm trying to make here is with Bill,
what helped me,
when I first started I was just full omnivore.
And I also wanted to gravitate
and let go of some habitual eating patterns
that were deeply ingrained.
Just like you described, exactly how you described.
And so I'd already, I'd been off dairy milk for years,
so that wouldn't have been a good place for me to start.
So, I'm just sharing to kind of give an idea.
And our old buddy, Dan Buettner, "Blue Zones,"
I kind of went with his approach,
which was here are all these hotspots around the world
in a good way.
Blue spots around the world.
Blue zones.
Blue zones where people are living to over 100.
And what are the concepts that they all share?
And one of 'em is eating very little meat products.
So, the idea was you can eat it once or twice a month
and probably won't have a big health impact on you.
And so, I did that.
That's how I approached it.
So, I would and eat meat every two weeks.
I give myself every two weeks
'cause it's also how I quit smoking cigarettes.
I smoked cigarettes in my early 20s,
and it's the same idea.
I just, I don't wanna get into that
because it involved a different bad habit.
But I saved up this thing that I wanted so badly
'til the end of the day or in this case two weeks,
and then eventually what happens is it falls away.
In the course of meat eating,
what you'll find, if you do that,
you put a container where you can have it,
so that it makes it easier to say no in the interim.
And then when you get there, you eat it and you enjoy it.
But eventually what's going
to happen is your taste buds will change.
I think that's the biggest, surprising thing to me is
when you first start going plant-based
and you've been eating a lot of meat,
it may be the flavor, you lack a certain,
you don't have the flavors that you are used to
in your meals.
But the more you eat plants,
when you go back to eating meat,
even 'cause I went from twice a month to once a month,
and when you go back to it,
pretty soon you'll notice it's actually the meat
that doesn't have the flavor
and everything else has a lot more flavor.
It's all the spices and the flavors and the sauces.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so, that I think could be helpful to you.
I don't know if it will be, it could be.
And then the other thing I would say is
social pressure wise, Crested Butte,
it's in, you know, sometimes living in certain places,
it can be very challenging
because there are not a lot of options,
especially if you're not cooking for yourself all the time.
So, I do understand that.
And I would say, look for, you know,
Chinese food, Thai food.
Look for places that have a good option for you
that might not be what you're normally eating,
but really good, healthy plant-based options
'cause Italian, you know,
a lot of ethnic food does have that, Indian.
Yeah, I don't mean to be insensitive to the location
or the geographic location and whatever constraints
that presents, but I will say this,
your response is spoken like a true normie, like non-addict.
Because everything you said does not work for me.
(Adam laughs)
Like, the idea, like in the smoking example,
that you would like, "Okay, well I'm trying to quit smoking,
"so I'm just gonna like save that cigarette
"for the end of the day-"
That's not what it was.
Do you want me to tell you what it was?
What?
So, I would save it.
Every time I had the urge to smoke a cigarette,
I would just realize when you get home,
you can have a big bong hit.
That was the replacement.
That was a replacement.
That actually does sound like an addict.
Yes, yes, yes.
But equally not workable in practice.
I don't think that works for Bill.
Here's the thing, like yeah.
I think it like, this is a thing that people
who are not addicts or alcoholics struggle to understand.
Like, if you're a normal person, you're like,
"Oh, I'll just have it like once a month.
"And that works great for me."
For me, that doesn't work at all
because it keeps me connected to the thing
that's the problem.
And I can't truly be free
until I'm totally liberated from it.
So, if you were to tell me, and I've told this,
I've given this example many times on the podcast,
so forgive me if you heard me say this before,
but if you told me,
"Look, you can go to In-N-Out Burger like once a week,
"and that's all the meat you're gonna eat."
I would spend five days a week obsessing upon
when I could go to In-N-Out Burger
and get that cheeseburger.
Like, the amount of mental energy
that would go into that would just be unbelievable.
So, I'm not free of that obsession until I'm truly,
you know, distanced from it completely
because I don't have,
because of the addict gene in me or whatever it is,
like I don't have that luxury.
And if I was told I could eat meat once a week,
then three months from now, that would be twice a week,
a month later, that would be four times a week.
And then, you know, blink,
and I'm just eating meat all the time.
Like, that's way it works for me.
So, I have to, and I realize like
maybe I'm wired differently
than the average human being is listening to this.
That's just what works for me.
Like, I have to completely step over the line
and not go back.
And with that, there's some discomfort for a couple weeks.
It is like detoxing off a drug.
You're like, I really want that thing.
I crave that thing.
The only way out is through.
You get through a couple weeks of it.
Those cravings start to dissipate.
A month later, you're barely thinking about it.
And then you wake up and you realize like,
"Wow, I haven't thought of that thing in quite some time.
"Like, I guess I'm free from it."
And that to me is a more powerful long lasting way
to do this.
Although for a lot of people like they're like you.
They're like, "Well, I can kind of dabble here and there.
"And it's not a problem."
Like, I wish, you know.
Truly, I wish.
You make my example sound (laughs)
And also for me it's like, oh, these, it's like,
"Okay, here are these blue zones people.
"They barely eat meat."
So, you look at that as,
"Well, I have a license to eat meat a couple times a month,"
whereas I'm the extreme and I'm like,
"Well, I'm just getting rid of that altogether."
But my point is is that I don't do that.
Like, the meat that I was talking about was chicken or beef
or whatever, I don't touch that at all.
So, what happens is you get to a place
where you realize actually it's not good food.
There's no reason to do it.
So, all those reasons.
So, in my case, that's how it happened.
So, in my case, I was like,
I don't have a desire anymore
for either of those two things.
But I couldn't go cold turkey because for what,
I could have I guess, but I decided not to
and it worked for me.
But let me throw this one at you.
As this ambassador for the oceans,
the idea that you would eat seafood
and then quote, unquote, classify it as sustainable,
see that to me-
No, I have, I have, I have,
so I know what sustainable seafood actually is.
I understand, I understand.
But I think that that,
like when we're talking about that dissonance gap,
like that gap between what you stand for,
which is the beauty and purity and majesty of the oceans,
and then like eating a sentient animal from said ocean,
to me those things don't exactly line up.
So, maybe just something to think about.
I'll think about it.
It's not the first time I've thought about it.
See?
There's the psychic drain.
I know-
Because you know on some level you're like,
"This is an inconsistency."
A lot of the best watermen I know also are fishermen.
We're not talking about them though.
Okay?
We're talking about you.
(Adam laughs)
Anyway, Bill, you have a couple of options there.
(everyone laughs)
That's okay.
You have a couple of options.
I would go with Rich's option.
But if it doesn't work for you, come on over to my side.
All right, we'll see how it goes.
Check in with us in a couple months.
We're going to Iowa for this next question.
And I love it.
I don't think we've been to Iowa yet.
Have we?
By the way, can I make a plug?
We need some questions, people.
Call us.
We didn't call out the voicemail number.
Let's do it.
Let's call it out.
What is it?
Do you know it?
It's 424-235-4626.
That's 424-235-4626.
Operators are standing by.
Yes.
Call us if you are going, well, no, here we go.
Hello guys, my name is Evan.
I'm 20 years old pursuing entrepreneurship from Iowa.
I wanted to ask this question
because I hear this statement so often from my parents
and a lot of older people, and it really bothers me.
So the statement is, "but you're young."
This really annoys me
because this kind of triggers a self assumption
that I'm not doing the right thing while I'm quote "young,"
no matter what it is,
especially as a person that is pursuing something
other than college.
Even though I'm doing the right things to progress
towards my goals.
These older people usually make me feel
like I'm doing the wrong thing or not doing enough.
Also, how do I enjoy the moment
while I go through this process
when I might be doing all this work,
but not seeing any of the progress in the present time?
But with that being said, I think it'd be great
for you both to give an objective statement
that could apply to all young people,
so we might have an idea of what the right
and wrong things are.
I know this is a pretty dense question,
so maybe there's a possibility to create
into a section of one of the wrongs.
I know it would be very beneficial
to a lot of people listening.
Whatever happens, I appreciate you guys taking the time
for these questions, and I hope you have a great day.
Thanks.
Oh, the youth.
Yes.
The gen Z.
As a representative of older people,
I'd like to hear your take on this.
The gen X take.
Yes.
I think, you know, listen, it is an open ended question.
It can be interpreted so many different ways.
But I think it's interesting to get a question like that
because it shows you,
'cause often we don't get that.
You get it at home, but I don't have 20 year olds at home,
so I don't get that same kind of viewpoint too often.
So, it's cool to hear it unfiltered here.
Yeah, I mean, I'm around a lot of people
that are in Evan's age bracket,
and, you know, I am aware of how,
look, there's something like beautiful about young people,
you know, shirking the trends of their elders
and, you know, believing that they know what's best,
you know.
And as an older person, you're like, there's so much,
you don't know what you don't know, you know?
And so, as an older person,
you always wanna like save people from making mistakes.
And oftentimes those people need to make those mistakes.
And then other times they're right.
And that's what's incredible about young people.
Like, we can point our finger as old men and be like,
"These crazy kids," but this is the way of the world.
Like, the youth inherit the earth
and they re-shape it in their image.
And there's something, you know, to be respected about that.
So, I appreciate Evan's question.
Yes, it is a bit vague and open ended.
It's really kind of hard to get a grip
on what exactly these older people are telling you
that you're doing that's wrong.
Like, I don't understand the context
that's being hurled at you as a specific criticism.
So, without knowing enough specifics, it's hard to,
you know, give you a completely concrete answer,
but I'll do my best.
And I think the first thing I would say is
that I feel strongly that youth, your 20s,
is the time in your life for trying lots of things,
exposing yourself to as many experiences
and cultures and jobs and careers as you possibly can
and being okay with changing your mind, changing your plans,
changing gears, and being even better with failing.
This is the time to do it.
Like, not in your 40s when you have a mortgage and a partner
and a car payment.
This is the time.
And I think that at odds with this and probably
where some of these older people are coming from
is this culture that we live in
that reinforces this mentality that we're in a race.
And if you're not on a certain pre-approved track,
that you're falling behind.
But falling behind what exactly?
So much of this is like illusion and projection.
But that projection or that fear comes
from a very specific place.
Because as a parent, I can sympathize with their concern
because we all want our kids to be happy, productive,
safe, secure.
We only know what we know,
and what we know is how we did it
and how our parents did it.
And breaking free of social paradigms,
like when you see a young person who's like,
"I'm not gonna follow that program.
"I'm gonna do it my own way,"
can be scary for an older person or a parent
because it's not only a threat
to kind of sometimes our values
or the way we made our way in the world
and the way we'd like to see our children make it,
like we want to pass down our wisdom,
but also a threat to that compulsion
that we have as parents for control and for certainty.
But like I said, those impulses are quite often
generally wrongheaded
and they're based on this kind of illusion
of control anyway.
So, what I say to you, Evan,
is that you should follow your heart,
you should pursue what gets you excited,
what gets you out bed in the morning.
I would suggest
that you might enjoy reading David Epstein's book "Range."
David who came up earlier on the podcast.
Got a double mention.
I know.
He's getting a double mention today.
What's up, David?
Where's that check?
And in that book, it's sort of a canvasing
of all these amazingly successful people
across a wide variety of fields.
And David realized that kind of what unites these people
or the trends that he sees in the arc of their life is
that these people were dabblers.
They tried many, many things
before they finally settled on the one thing
that they found purpose in.
And all of those dabbling endeavors that they did
over the course of their life kind of come into play
to create this stew that makes them kind of the only person
who could do the thing that they end up doing
'cause it's this mix of interesting past experiences
and skillsets.
But I say this with two caveats,
and the first is that, you know, following your heart,
pursuing what gets you excited is not an excuse
to be irresponsible.
You still have to live in the world.
And if you're gonna do this, you have to live lean,
so you can invest whatever money and time you have
in experiences and not get captured by debt or obligations
that don't serve you.
So, that's super important.
Don't end up leveraging yourself,
so that you owe a bunch of people or you have payments
or you're in an apartment that's too expensive for you.
All of those things.
Like, try to live as leanly as possible.
And that just provides more opportunities
and also serves your ability to like change gears
if you want to.
And the second thing I would say,
and I say this because I have no idea if you should
or should not go to college or should
or should not be doing what you're doing right now,
is to do a really honest and open inventory of yourself
and your actions
because perhaps just maybe your elders are correct,
and you're not seeing something that they can see.
And because you're young
and, you know, full of vim and vigor,
you have your blinders up to, you know,
something they're trying to express to you
that you've just sort of willingly
or unwillingly blinded yourself to.
So, in that inventory,
it's about doing a really honest accounting of your actions
to identify possible blind spots.
Like, are there areas in your life
where maybe you are being irresponsible
or reactive or petulant, and what are your true motivations
for what you're pursuing right now?
Are they truly born out of like a passion
and an intuitive knowing pull
towards something personally meaningful
that is girded with purpose?
Or is there a little bit of like fuck you to your parents
built in there somewhere
because that's true of a lot of young people,
maybe most young people.
Like, to what extent are you being driven,
not by this honorable, you know, sentiment,
but by some kind of latent resentment
or other kind of petty emotion that could trip you up
and, you know, cause a lot of undue suffering in your life.
So, I think getting that part right is
absolutely fundamental and key.
Getting clear on the motivation.
Yeah, like being really clear
with what it is you're exactly doing
and what your motivations are.
And the only way to get that clarity is
to really do this inside work.
And everyone's like, "Well, what is the inside work?"
And it's hard to give a concrete, clear definition of that,
but, you know, it's something that you discover
through kind of grappling with your interior emotions.
And that can be done with a therapist,
it can be done through journaling,
it can be done through mindfulness practices.
But I really think talking these things out with somebody
who is skilled at helping you kind of get this type
of clarity is really important.
So, if you're capable of seeing a therapist
or being in some kind of therapeutic construct,
I think that would be helpful in trying to cobble together
that kind of inventory and clarity.
The other piece that he mentioned was progress,
like not feeling like he was making any progress.
And to that I would say that nothing in life is for not,
everything good takes a lot longer
than you can possibly imagine.
I'm an example of that.
And if you feel like you're not making,
Adam raised his hand.
If you're not making progress under your definition
of what progress is, perhaps you could change,
you might want to change the definition of progress
or change or extend the timeline,
and ask yourself,
irrespective of all of that progress regression,
like what are you learning along the way
that could be helpful to you in other facets of life?
Because even if you feel like you're not making progress,
if you're grappling with whatever problems you're trying
to solve or business you're trying to build
or whatever it is, everything that you're experiencing,
particularly the setbacks and the failures
and how you kind of tackle and overcome obstacles,
that's the curriculum for whatever you end up doing later.
Even if you never make progress
in let's say this business venture
that you're, you know, striving towards building,
you are learning many important life lessons along the way
that I have no doubt will come into play in a positive
and material way later in your life.
So, I guess that's my big speech.
Be nimble.
You know, if you really feel
like you're not making progress,
you can't be afraid to, you can't hold on so tightly.
You should be able to let go.
And if it's not working, change gears, switch it up.
This is what your 20s is for.
You know, the youth is built for this.
And if you are living lean and ensuring that you're not
under any kind of undue financial constraints,
then you're able to do that, and you can pivot your energy
and just do something else and not beat yourself up
as if you had failed at something
despite whatever these elders are telling you
and kind of, you know, apply the lessons that you learned
in that past experience into a new one.
Well said.
It's the exact speech I give to the scoopers on the line
every morning.
The scoopers on the line?
Yeah.
What is a scooper and what line?
Ben and Jerry's.
Oh.
(everyone laughs)
The young scoopers.
I forgot that you have a day job.
Oh.
Just so we're clear, this is a joke, everybody.
Like, some people actually think you work
at Ben and Jerry's.
I don't work at Ben and Jerry's-ish.
I think it's a great question.
I think you handled it.
I think-
I mean, the question's pretty vague.
Like, I can't really tell exactly
what his elders are upset about or what-
But you can tell
that there's some sort
of generational pressure he's getting.
He's getting pressure from his parents or some other people
that are like, you know-
"You should go to college.
"This is crazy."
"What you're doing isn't gonna work."
All I can say is what I was doing
certainly didn't seem like it was working
for a long, long, long time.
And so, you know, but at the same time, I got to a point
where there was no turning back.
So, there is something to the commitment of it.
But core to that in your example.
There was some knowing that you were a writer.
Like, "I am a writer."
What that looks like in the world
and how I make a living doing that
that's where you had to be flexible and nimble,
and there was a lot of different incarnations of that
along the way.
There was.
I was a writer.
But you were always a writer and you knew that.
So, you had that self-awareness and self knowledge.
You know, maybe Evan believes in his heart of hearts,
he is an entrepreneur, he is a business person.
It's unclear.
But I think that's where it all starts, right?
And if you don't know that,
all the more reason to do, as David Epstein would suggest,
dabble, you know, spend your 20s exposing yourself
to lots and lots of things
'cause how are you supposed to know?
I do think there is this enormous pressure on young people
that you're supposed to know what you want to do
with your life.
I mean, you go to college at 18,
and you have to choose a major.
It's insane.
That's what I was about to say is like,
as much as fun as I had college and meeting my friends
and all that,
in all honesty, I shouldn't have gone for two years.
Like, because I didn't take anything specific
to something I wanna do later, which is fine too.
Mostly the best thing about college
for me was meeting friends and reading some books
that helped me down the line and at the time.
But like the bottom line is
if you do ever decide to go back,
you're gonna know what you want to go back for,
and you're gonna get more out of the experience,
and you'll probably pay more attention.
So, I don't think there's any big problem
with punting college at all.
And I'm with you.
I think that this program that people are on is a bit crazy.
Yeah, and I would say that, you know,
my history demonstrates, you know,
me being a terrible example of all the advice
that I just gave.
Like, I went to law school.
I didn't know why I was going to law school.
I ended up practicing law for like a really long time.
Never enjoying it, never having any passion for it.
But so wed to the idea that this is what I had to do
because I had invested so much into it.
And I had put myself in a position
where I couldn't be nimble,
and I was overspending and created, you know,
financial instability that made it even worse.
It was like terrible.
And I'm just like that-
Even that won't work out.
But that's why I feel so strongly about this.
Like, please don't do what I did.
You know, please don't do it.
And that's probably all your,
the older generation is trying to tell you
is please don't fuck up like we fucked up.
But at the same time, the fear would be like,
oh, go to law school, it's secure.
And yeah, if you lease a BMW and live in a nice condo
and have a prestigious job,
then I can go to the cocktail party
and tell my friends that you're doing awesome.
And that's fucked up.
And also, unless, we don't know,
Evan could be a young Walter White in training.
We just don't know what his business is.
Do you think he purposely was vague
to not incriminate himself?
Walter White shout out.
That's just a joke, Evan.
I hope you're doing good in Iowa.
All right, well thus concludes another "Roll On."
There was a minute there
where I thought we were gonna land this
in well under two hours, but here we are again,
well over two hours.
And we did leave stuff out, we promise.
We did.
You feel good?
Yeah.
I feel good to great.
Good to great.
Yeah.
Your semi deepness just got a little bit deeper.
You know what?
I love that we gave two polar opposite answers.
That's what it's about.
I think we should strive,
I'll strive for questions where we totally disagree
and that way it gives the listener options.
Yeah, I think the answer to that question would be good
as a standalone video.
We should put it up.
So, we'll work on that.
There you go.
All right, my friend until next time.
In the meantime, thank you for joining us today.
I appreciate your attention.
I don't take it for granted.
You can follow Adam @AdamSkolnick on the internet.
I'm @RichRoll everywhere.
Once again, we do love the questions
and could use some messages,
so if you've got something on your mind you want us
to discuss the phone number is 424-235-4626.
Show notes as always are available on the episode page
at richroll.com.
And please don't forget to subscribe to the show.
That really does help us out a lot on YouTube, on Apple,
on Spotify, wherever you enjoy this content.
This show is a team effort.
I certainly don't do it alone.
So, thanks go out today to my team,
Jason Camillo for audio engineering,
production show notes, and interstitial music,
Blake Curtis and Dan Drake
for handling the video side of things,
Daniel Solos for graphics, AJ Apodiete for TikToks,
more video content, Dave Greenberg for portraits,
Georgia Whaley for copywriting,
DK for advertiser relationships,
and theme music as always by Tyler Trapper and Harry.
Appreciate you guys.
Love you.
See you back here in a couple days
with another amazing episode.
Until then my friend, Adam, last words.
Thanks for all the great reporting out from Beijing,
all you crew of intrepid reporters.
True, true that.
Make sure you make sure you go see the great wall
in winter before you come back home.
Safely.
Peace.
Plants.
Namaste.
(gentle music)